freedom of movement for people and labor
is an enshrined principle in the EU at
the very heart of the single market but
as many a doctor nurse architect IT
engineer struggling to get their
qualifications recognised in a third
country have discovered it's not that
simple it's taken mep steering
legislation through parliament many
years to get professional qualifications
recognised across the union lemma be
heated is it wanna sit you know sit down
Towanda [ __ ] I reckon you don't allah
treaty may I leave I'm on a difficult i
complex Pascal yeah the turn the
papillae don't imagine you miss active
affair in the trim of s reconnaissance
the qualification MEP s were square
behind her on an issue which represented
a rare enough moment of cross party
unity a lot of effort went into the
establishment of a transnational alert
system for medics barred from practicing
as much work to into the introduction of
the European professional card
congressman Keller skis present has
affirmed the certificate chronic aquí la
cámara de beneficio deposit of the
Haqqanis hasta la formación de la Tito
the local official personnel we were so
happy the sample if he casts very table
mom okay a signal with the talk there is
in Europe of obstinately high
unemployment levels especially among
young people the question is whether
mutual professional recognition will
help not directly says one MEP but it
may with Europe's demographic skills gap
miss Leticia chiffon does pushed him too
far if tepid RF in under England and get
in conduit well if it's heretofore
crafted these Polish nurses are a case
in point it's not just the lack of
language skills that held them back it's
the lack of recognition of their
training and skills which they got when
joining the EU
Polishness have good qualification
working with many country before
European Union coming to European Union
this is discrimination next step as the
wrangling with member states is done and
over it's up to them to put the changes
into action